kid where are you mrs. dark madam out
there devastating where are the snacks
I'm getting them right now man
is there anyone Wow your DJ Khaled
you're spider-man what are you doing
here I'm going to this finals party
Starks party I'm going to look can we
get a picture it's good-looking thank
you
Wow me that's definitely a first another
one another another I gotta box in give
the show finally here we go
good evening Peter oh you have 576
possible well shooter from the nation ha
ha ha I can keep that suit yeah doesn't
fit me where's our next retreat
what next mission we'll call you all
right that's not a hug then just grab
the top for you all right there yet all
right kid
good luck out there
hey Peter you going tonight I can't
tonight I got the astark internship
what's up guys
here's my report for tonight I stopped
the grand theft bicycle hey could you do
me a favor hold on to that there's
anybody by I helped us old lady and she
bought me a churro so I was nice I just
feel like I could be doing more wait a
minute you guys aren't the real Avengers
hope gives it away new move I'm working
on not bad Hey
these weapons are crazy dangerous listen
fear they're people who handle the sort
of thing can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
activating parachute
the world's changing boys time we
changed too
this is my chance to prove myself we
have a Spanish quiz you gotta get better
at this part of the job I'm sad oh I'm
intimidated
where you going what are you hiding
Peter I'm just getting younger by
there's a ton of other subsystems in
here but are all disabled by the
training wheels protocol because mr.
start treating me like a kid could you
are a kid
yeah you can stop a boss with his bare
hands
[Music]
and